[Musique]
gare du nord à paris
le décor de noël est trompeur
en apparence rien ne semble avoir changé
la gare se classe toujours parmi les
plus importantes dans le monde en terme
de trafic avec plus de 200 millions de
voyageurs par an mais depuis un an une
ligne a vu son niveau de sécurité
drastiquement relevé le thalys qui
relient paris au nord de l'europe à bord
de ce train un attentat a été évitée de
justesse en août 2015
à partir de cette limite interdiction de
filmer il faut continuer en caméra
discrète portiques de sécurité fouilles
aléatoires scanner une présence
policière importante sur les quais
mais aussi à l'intérieur des rames un
dispositif qui contraste avec la
destination de notre train gare du midi
à bruxelles
l'accès aux quais est libre sans aucun
contrôle
face à ce constat une accusation a été
distillées au fil des mois
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
la belgique ne serait pas à la hauteur
le gouvernement a réagi mission numéro 1
renforcé le contrôle des frontières
c'est prévu dans notre un projet de loi
c'est à dire quand on couvre tous les
transports six nations les trains
internationaux également hier et
aujourd'hui c'est grand oral pour
l'exécutif belge mettre au point une
législation de contrôle aux frontières
c'est la mission d'un des membres du
gouvernement en particulier françois
belot ministre fédéral chargé de la
mobilité ont pris ce qu'on accole années
difficiles qu'on a connue l'année passée
d'années avant comme d'attentats on
essaie de de trouver justement comment
renforcer la sécurité dans les
transports publics tout en assurant la
liberté des uns et des autres d'aller en
toute quiétude
aujourd'hui en commission il est venu
présenter la feuille de route de son
ministère le recueil d'informations sur
les passagers entrant dans l'union
européenne
un dossier brûlant discuté depuis plus
de dix ans c'est ce qu'on appelle le pnr
censé recueillir les informations des
voyageurs pour les liaisons aériennes
la belgique elle a décidé d'aller encore
plus loin
la volonté qui est exprimée par le
ministre de l'intérieur est relayée par
le gouvernement et d'implémenter ça
aussi pour les liaisons très
internationale c'est à mon sens la
commission européenne qui devrait
prendre en main cette question comme la
question était prise en main pour le
transport aérien
le pnr aérien les états membres doit le
mettre en place d'ici mai 2018 en
l'appliquant à tous les modes de
transport la belgique se retrouve au
centre d'une polémique ce dossier alain
gignac l'a couvert pour le grand
quotidien belge le soir
l'opinion publique n'est au courant de
ce projet que depuis peu c'est l'un des
projets importants que semble s'être
fixé pour la législature yan yan bonne
le ministre l'intérieur
c'est un projet qu'il est qu'il espère
mener à bien au plus vite pour montrer
que la belgique est le bon élève de la
classe
du point de vue politique ça a donné
lieu à une série de débats mais très
souvent les débats ont tourné court
parce que le gouvernement avait choisi
de travailler dans l'urgence il a
demandé l'urgence pour le traitement du
du projet de loi à la ligue des droits
de l'homme on est très vigilants ce
projet de pnr belge c'est avant tout une
grande opération de communication mais
avec des conséquences très graves
notre ministre de l'intérieur veut
certainement laver plus blanc que blanc
comme s'ils devaient faire preuve
d'encore plus de d'initiatives pour
lutter contre le terrorisme que pour
comme pour se reconstruire une
réputation
il faut savoir que notre ministre de
l'intérieur depuis toujours
il fait partie d'un parti nationaliste
flamand il est adepte d'un état
sécuritaire et donc il a le fantasme de
la surveillance de masse ce fantasme de
la sécurité et d'un état policier qui se
met en place aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
il y voit une opportunité pour mettre
des pans entiers de leur programme en
oeuvre la sécurité dans les transports
l'enjeu majeur dans l'union européenne
avec une question centrale où placer le
curseur entre la sûreté nationale et les
libertés individuelles
[Musique]